[Music]  I have to say the world has become a  better place to live mainly the European  part of the world what is new is the  question duality related to environment  we have to focus on climate change as a  commission we did it but we have to  improve our efforts climate change is  the major problem of the future we have  to go back to our educational systems  become more way more proactive we have  to link the educational system to the  labor market we have to take care of the  young generation the young generation is  the future of a society that's a fact  that's not a nicety I say  I would like to launch a vapid wave to  everyone the two votes for the European  elections and everyone has to know this  very day I am Europe everyone has to ask  himself if everyone would vote in favor  of the extremists what would be the  European reality of tomorrow so vote  votes  [Music]